[SPEAKER_01]: Third Wealsun in the evening as Paul Rivero returns to Monmurg on the coast air from his adventures on Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so what happens is the group returns to Monmurg on the Kosair and they dock at the Royal Docks.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not normally where these ships dock, however, for whatever reason they were given permission to do that, most likely because you were on the boat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I figured.
[SPEAKER_01]: After you dock, basically what happens is an attendant says to you and Jude, you guys are wanted to debrief with Prince Jeon and Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude is supposed to go talk to Lord Jamis, and you are supposed to go talk to Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Jamis does not have the authority to debrief you, and that's kind of why that is the case.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jeon wants to basically get
[SPEAKER_01]: What you observed directly from your mouth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you're led up the stairway, the private stairway, passed several guards, into the Prince's, you know, royal palace.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your home, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And led to John's office.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you enter, he's basically already there, and he has somewhat of a concerned look on his face.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's kind of like looking at this map of what you can tell is the outer islands, the Salinmoor Bay to the north, and then the Jerley Bay to the south.
[SPEAKER_01]: But when you walk in, he says, Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sit down, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who says this to me?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jeon, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I sit down.
[SPEAKER_01]: I heard there was some trouble on Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've gotten reports that the ship we sent you on was overwhelmed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: There were 300 marines on that ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: All gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe a hundred made it off.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it is sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's also hobgoblins that had taken over the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tell me more of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fairwind is a traitor.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do you know this?
[SPEAKER_00]: We... okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is Jamis in the room with this?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, he's not.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just you and Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously, he wants to get your point of view... First.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in private, which is... Sus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe not sus, but I think what that kind of tells you is that he's not just completely trusting everybody else right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: He wants to know what you know... First hand.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Before you say it to everybody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I'll explain to him, um...
[SPEAKER_00]: We sailed to the island, you know, we got there ready.
[SPEAKER_00]: I said, you know, be ready in case it was taken over.
[SPEAKER_00]: We had dropped 50 Marines on one shore side.
[SPEAKER_00]: I explained which one that is to them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Southern Beacon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then we had docked our ship in the harbor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me, Jude, and 20 other Marines got off onto the docks and started scouting ahead, and all of a sudden we came under fire from the towers up above, so we had to storm that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me and Jude thought about turning around, but we looked behind and saw Sahaugin tearing up the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, just swarming it.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, everyone on that ship was gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm pretty sure it sank and is in the harbor, and everyone on it's dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: We stormed inside and we got to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_00]: We met up with some Marines that were resisting there that were stationed on the Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: They knew nothing about what happened to Fairwind or anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now those were Fairwind's men.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said Farrowind was a traitor though.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so here's where it gets interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they didn't know anything about like how the hobgoblins had gotten into the helm or if there's any marines fighting left or what was aboard Farrowind.
[SPEAKER_00]: But they were just stationed in there, you know, holding.
[SPEAKER_00]: So...
[SPEAKER_00]: So they were under siege as well?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, they were under siege as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: We linked up with them and we decided, I made a plan with them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Me and a group of Marines decided to storm the helm by going up over the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we had the other Marines that were left to create a diversion.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't really know what's out of them, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: We snuck inside and we snuck around the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: We got to Lord Fairwind's safe room, I guess, where I thought he would be.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Inner Sanctum.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, the Inner Sanctum.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I had scouted ahead and I could see and hear visibly, like I saw him dealing, who was he dealing with?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, he was making deals with the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was talking to them, standing around in the same room with them walking.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, wait, there were Toli in the hill at that time?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do you know they were Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: I saw them and we captured them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go on.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you actually witnessed Ward Fairwind talking to them, walking around in the same room with them making deals.
[SPEAKER_00]: What were they talking about?
[SPEAKER_00]: They were talking about removing the powder from Helma.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, they were talking about removing the powder that kept away the sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then another thing that Fairwind said is, well, what the Toli said is, we noticed you took most of it for yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and so I explained to him that Lord Fairwind, that I think he was trying to split away or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was his idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: He took most of the powder for himself.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he removed the powder from Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Most, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's how the Sahaugin got up and swarmed it.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, they said you had four barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of the stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so after we take Lord Farrowing, I put him under arrest and, you know, he gave a big fit about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He tried to play guilty.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, we took one Toli alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: We moved down to the, uh, secret cave system that is, was unknown, um, along the back coastline behind the castle or keep, whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um,
[SPEAKER_00]: We were walking down the stairs over on the side of this cave.
[SPEAKER_00]: All of a sudden we were spotted.
[SPEAKER_00]: We killed Toli and threw him over the side into the water because he was a dead weight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Fairwind, I was trying to get to the front, pushed me off over the side.
[SPEAKER_00]: I fell in the water.
[SPEAKER_00]: I got pulled back up though, but he threw himself over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or no, he got pushed over.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he escaped.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't know what happened to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He could be dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: He could be alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we were able to fight and kill our way down there, the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_00]: We
[SPEAKER_00]: Built a raft.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that what we did?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we built a raft and we sailed out of there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We took four barrels and we were able to keep the sahaugin off as we got out of there.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many barrels are there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty-five, I think, was our count.
[SPEAKER_00]: We took four because that's what we could take.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the rest were removed?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, everything else was gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who else witnessed Fairwind speaking to the Toli agents?
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, nobody else.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was just me.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're the only one that has definitive witness to his betrayal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your compatriots, how much have you told them about his?
[SPEAKER_00]: His what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Treason.
[SPEAKER_00]: I told them that he is a traitor, I told them that he was making deals with Toli, and that's really it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't get too specific about it, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: They believed me over him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, it doesn't really make sense, you know, because, in fact, what he told, what he told, Alden Reyes, he said that they just, he put all of his men, like, he had them all give up their arms and put them under ground or whatever, like, in the
[SPEAKER_00]: Holdings, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: We never found the Marines that he had, but they basically just let the hobgoblins walk in.
[SPEAKER_00]: So...
[SPEAKER_00]: That doesn't sound very...
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's your opinion that Fairwind allowed the hobgoblins to take over the helm, and his men were...
[SPEAKER_00]: The hobgoblins were working with Toli, we believe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, which is strange, even though the Duke of Berghof is known to employ hobgoblin mercenaries, so there's some involvement of him in this as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, and they were red, the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if that's...
[SPEAKER_01]: I've seen them before.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're red-skinned men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I've never seen them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They live in the mountains, the crystal mist, which the Duke of Berghof, his duchy, backs up against it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he has some dealings with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're easier handled actually than most humanoids are, but still this is very disconcerting that they were used in this situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's basically... Is there any idea how they got on the island?
[SPEAKER_00]: We never really found out specifically.
[SPEAKER_00]: We kind of had to get out of there.
[SPEAKER_00]: We had to get back and report.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I didn't know if you were sending ships our way or anything for reinforcements or what.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we received a signal from the Southern Beacon.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume that's the first squad that came off.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm pretty sure, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That there was danger.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And basically they told us not to send any more ships until things were all clear.
[SPEAKER_01]: The sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume that's why.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: We received that just after you landed.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I assume that when your ship was being attacked we were warmed off because of that threat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: But from what I'm hearing, it is okay now for us to proceed.
[SPEAKER_01]: We might want to take some barrels with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like I said, I don't know really what happened with those marines in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's probably definitely some hobgoblins still on the island.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there was this big ship that you could see sometimes in the distance that would break through the fog.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's where they were like moving off the powder and that's where they were holding most of their shit I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: But that ship left.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that was the Toli ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: What was it?
[SPEAKER_01]: It was like a giant...
[SPEAKER_01]: It was called Sea Ghost.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a Sea Ghost.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you had heard people talk that Kane Tolley was the guy that captained that ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: We think that Kane Tolley was the captain of the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or at least that's what Fairwind said.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what Fairwind was...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: No doubt that's where the hobgoblins came from.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or at least that seems like the most reasonable place.
[SPEAKER_01]: We saw them sending ships back and forth to the cave and out and back.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where they were storing the powder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, offloading it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I am going to have Lord Jamis send a flotilla of troops and ships to Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we are going to retake the smugglers' caves, get the remaining powder if there is any.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have the area blockaded at this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that will continue.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wish to talk to you a little bit about the compatriots that you went with.
[SPEAKER_01]: I understand that most of them were Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: There were some men of note.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick being the one that Lord Jamis suggested, and then he had two agents with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge, who I've heard of in passing, and then also a Jude, which I understand is a wizard for hire.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, we questioned previously.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've had meetings with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are your thoughts on these men?
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty solid.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they're good at what they do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are these the only three men that you discussed Fairwind's treachery with?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they basically almost all witnessed the Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: When you say all, the barracks, the men and the barracks?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was, how many, there was five, was there five, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was Merrick, Gouge, Jude was with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Am I forgetting one?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's it, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So two others, and these were just Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, just your bottom-of-the-mill Marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, they'll be talked to, but they need to be quieted, definitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll leave Jamis to do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, they report to Jamis anyways.
[SPEAKER_01]: But Merrick acquitted himself with honor, I assume.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_01]: He obviously...
[SPEAKER_01]: Was loyal to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you send him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jamis recommended him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, yeah, they're loyal.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not gonna mess with us.
[SPEAKER_00]: I doubt it.
[SPEAKER_00]: What about Gouge?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, Gouge, he's fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: He makes quick decisions under pressure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not much of a threat, though, unless he's threatened upon.
[SPEAKER_00]: Professional.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, they're pretty professional, I'd say.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what are your feelings of this Jude character?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a pretty good wizard, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the job that you gave him was to protect me, and he did just fine doing that, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: They're very good fighters, though, I will say.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Paul, I do have something to speak with you about.
[SPEAKER_01]: Since you brought to my attention your investigation into your past, your history, your father, I thought on some things.
[SPEAKER_01]: And please think of this conversation as being one of a suggestion regarding your personal career path and how you can be most useful to your family in these times of need.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've noticed that you've dedicated yourself to
[SPEAKER_01]: What could be called Ledger Domain spycraft in a way.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think that very useful.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, to be honest,
[SPEAKER_01]: When your father, I knew him, I knew Grayson when we were young men and I was very, very impressed by his intelligence and actually the intelligence of your mother as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: They were both brilliant people.
[SPEAKER_01]: He talked often about the yellow substance and how
[SPEAKER_01]: Our state would only be free when we were the ones that produced it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if you know this, but that compound was given to us by the Duke of Berkhoff and he has quit giving.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're running out.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've been running out for decades.
[SPEAKER_01]: What was left in Helms Island and has been taken
[SPEAKER_01]: It was really only enough to last another three years.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've been desperate for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: But now that it has been removed, we have no time.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have no way to produce that ourselves.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't have that knowledge.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is what Grayson, maybe two decades ago, recognized and was committed to changing that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, all the greatest alchemists belong to Keoland.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or the Duke of Berkhoff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you know what I'm asking you?
[SPEAKER_01]: To go to either one and figure out if I can find something?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm asking you because I know you're capable of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you perhaps study the creation of this substance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Could you look into it to seek and quest to figure out a way to do it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: This would divert you from your main path.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you'd have to delve into the arcane arts.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you be willing to do that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most Oeridians are reluctant to go there.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, I see now that our negligence of the magical arts have led us to this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to develop wizards.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we do.
[SPEAKER_01]: This brings me to my second point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you feel like Jude is someone you would be willing to have tutor you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a good wizard.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very, very powerful wizard.
[SPEAKER_00]: He could teach me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Excellent.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've actually asked Lord Jamis to propose that to Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: From what I understand, Jude is someone that's very transactional.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, right now we have things that he would like.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think that if he could tutor you in the magical arts and give you the knowledge that he has, it would be very advantageous to our family.
[SPEAKER_01]: And to be honest, having a new prince of Monmurg that has the abilities of a wizard would be very advantageous as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I charge you
[SPEAKER_01]: Look into the magical arcane arts, please, as your father did and your mother did before you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll give you full leeway in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can do whatever you wish as long as it does not bring harm to the city or stigma to our names.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are magics, of course, that are illegal in Keoland, illegal in
[SPEAKER_01]: The Duchy of Berghof.
[SPEAKER_01]: Necromancy comes to mind primarily.
[SPEAKER_01]: But as long as no one knows of it, I'm not going to restrict your knowledge or where you seek knowledge.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you have my full permission to use any resources in the Royal Library to do research.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if there are things that you need to acquire, because I understand wizards have a need for esoteric components, I will do what I can there.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Great Market is visited by wizards world round.
[SPEAKER_01]: And even though we are having a very hard year of it, I assume that we will be able to find in the city, at least right now, things that you will require.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to have Jamis talk to Jude about his tutelage of you, but I would like to see that proceed in the next few weeks.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm giving you and he the charge to figure out this yellowish powder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: How to make it, where it comes from.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything we need to know regarding it.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have months before our supply will run out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now there are some other locations that we can look into.
[SPEAKER_01]: If Fairwind did indeed betray us, he should have a large amount of that somewhere on Fairwind Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do not wish to openly go to war with Fairwind at this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a traitor.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a prince of the principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has a large force of men and ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: So do we.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is true, but we're at war with Gradsul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right now, showing Gradsul our weakness, our division would be disastrous.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're going to let Fairwind get away with it?
[SPEAKER_01]: I did not say that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that the first thing that I would like to see you and you do is figure out where Fairwind has stored his amount.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then we strike.
[SPEAKER_01]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: He can play his games, we can play ours.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we do have a ticking clock here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because it will only be so long before we run out and
[SPEAKER_01]: In truth, Monmurg is the most exposed to the sahaugin threat of any of the other holdings of the principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that makes sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: If the sahaugin could destroy this town, this city, it would only be a matter of time before they reclaim.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long does one barrel put in the water last?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like a week?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not that long, from what I understand.
[SPEAKER_01]: The salting ships would have to go out once every two days with a barrel.
[SPEAKER_01]: But a small barrel covers quite a large range.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miles.
[SPEAKER_01]: And in fact, the entire Strait of Monmurg is covered by just one barrel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Usually what happens is they go up near the scimitars, dump the barrel in the water, and they let the current flow back towards this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been like this for
[SPEAKER_01]: It's been, we've done this for decades now, hundreds of years actually, 150.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, I'll get on, I'll start looking into that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now there's some politics here.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is why I don't want you to yell Fairwind's traitorous nature to the spires yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: What I'm hoping is we can negotiate with him and we can figure out a way to get the supply back or at least for him to give us some.
[SPEAKER_00]: You might want to grab those marines then and tell them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will have Lord Jamis take care of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_01]: One way or the other.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think they'll
[SPEAKER_01]: They're loyal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, they're loyal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because if I can avoid a war with Fairwind, I would do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want Keoland to see our weakness in that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: We look weak enough to that country as it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any kind of weakness between the princes themselves would lead to a direct attack, and I do not want to see that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another thing is we have looked very weak on the seas and it's because of some magical talisman this king totally seems to have with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've lost a few ships when we should not have.
[SPEAKER_01]: And until we figure out exactly what is happening there, I do not want to risk an attack on Keoland's navy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Jamis has some ideas as to what is causing this, and I'll discuss them with you later.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that actually your arcane abilities, if you have them, will do well in abjuring this advantage that the Toli have as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any kind of knowledge you can have with the arcane will help us greatly here, and I want you to be my interpreter into that world.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't trust anybody else.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't trust Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well... Has he given you enough reason not to do that?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, of course not.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he is not part of my family.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have no reason not to use him as an advisor.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would rather have you be an expert in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's understandable.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I think that would be most powerful, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: A wizard spy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, that's what the times require now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ship captains and good fighters are not what we need at this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there anything you wish to talk to me about?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me keep those four Marines under my command of my little group.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will consider that.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you wish to remain in contact with them, I can understand that.
[SPEAKER_01]: American Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, Merrick is of high rank and Lord Jamis has plans for him, but I'm sure that he can be drawn upon as required.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge is another issue entirely.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's something that Lord Jamis allocates as required.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if there's something, a mission that you think that
[SPEAKER_01]: Would require someone with that skill, then definitely I will allocate it to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: So come to me when you have an actual mission and those four are yours.
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the meantime, what I suggest is that you and Jude engage in the activities that you were engaging in beforehand.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do research into where and how this powder is created.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also look into where Fairwind may have taken it.
[SPEAKER_01]: This will require spies being sent to Fairwinds Island, maybe hiring informants, things like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: You'll have the money that you need for those things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: A good spy master knows how to delegate, so I suggest you learn how to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let your agents bring word to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cultivate a web.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't really have any agents.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can get them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jamis has told me that Jude actually is pretty adroit at doing this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I mean we have one guy, but that was three days ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Find more.
[SPEAKER_01]: Names has said that Jude is particularly skilled at bending people to his will through various means.
[SPEAKER_01]: Learn that skill also.
[SPEAKER_01]: Use him as your cutout.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your front man.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I hear what you're lying down.
[SPEAKER_01]: But tell me what he does.
[SPEAKER_01]: And tell me the agents that you have.
[SPEAKER_01]: And report to me what you learned.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Excellent.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now I suggest you go get some rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Will be done.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can meet with Jude tomorrow and discuss your plans.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're led from the room.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you go back to your room in the evening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually pretty happy to be there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You take off your still damp clothes for being dumped into the drink with a giant shark.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or my sizzled clothes from that tower that blasted in flames.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't shoot.